Preserving economic interests requires
trading and working with governments,
like,
for example,
trying to,
that violate human rights.
And there are some who would say,
well,
you can't do both.
You can't,
um,
go and talk to the Chinese about
stabilizing,
um,
the global economy and the steps that we
want them to take to,
uh,
to help us deal with,
obviously a,
an existential economic crisis and at
the same time lecture them about their
treatment of dissidence for prisoners or
the Falun Gong or Tibetans or what have
you.
I don't think that's right.
I think that the United States and
countries like trying to work together
on economic matters because it's in
their mutual interest to do so.
I don't think China or any other country
works with us on those issues,
um,
to do us a favor.
They do it because it's in their
interest to do so as well.
Um,
so I don't think we damage ourselves
diplomatically if we stand up for our
principals so long as we do it in a
intelligent way.
Um,
and that's the challenge of diplomacy.
It's,
it's doing more than one thing at one
time.
And any secretary of state,
um,
or any president,
who is up to the enormous challenge,
uh,
of those jobs should be able to do that.
Um,
and I also think that it's unrealistic
to think that,
uh,
that we can simply drop those issues.
You know,
you can go into a meeting with the
Chinese and say,
you know what,
we're,
we just can't afford to raise the case
of that dissident.
We can't afford to lecture them about
the port Tibetans because we've got to
save the global economy.
And then three months later,
something awful is going to happen in
Tibet.
And guess what?
The United States government is going to
have to say something about it because
it would be politically impossible not
to.
And then the Chinese having seen the
pattern of silence become even more
upset.
They'll say,
where does that come from?
We thought you weren't talking to us
about that stuff anymore.
And the diplomatic costs are even
greater.
So I think for,
you know,
realistic diplomatic reasons,
it's better just to be principled and
consistent and send the message out to
every country that we work with around
the world.
You know,
that's just part of doing business with
the United States that we're going to
raise those issues.
It's because it's who we are.
It's what we believe.
I Dunno about self determination,
but sovereignty,
a state sovereignty is often used as an
argument against intervening to stop
human rights abuses.
Um,
and it's a complicated set of arguments.
but certainly in cases where you have
extreme violence against civilians,
um,
the threat or reality of mass killing
and genocide,
I believe in,
in fact the United Nations has adopted a
principle of responsibility to protect,
to deal with those situations.
That if,
if a state is failing and it's
responsibility to protect its own people
from those kinds of abuses,
then the rest of the world has a
responsibility to step in in whatever
way may be effective.
Now,
what if we're talking about,
um,
less extreme violations of human rights
torture or a newspapers being closed
down or people being in prison because
of,
um,
because they're expressing their views.
Uh,
you know,
I think very few people argue that those
cases merit military intervention,
uh,
invading a country to take down it's
government.
But there are other tools that I think
are appropriate to use to pressure
countries to change their behavior,
uh,
partly because it's the right thing to
do,
partly because there are legal
obligations being violated when
governments violate human rights in
those ways.
And partly because we have a self
interest in,
um,
as Americans,
uh,
in,
in building a world in which governments
treat their people better than a lot of
reasons for that.
So,
um,
so I don't think that sovereignty is an
absolute bar to one country or one group
of people,
um,
promoting human rights beyond their
political borders.
The United States can't be an effective
champion of human rights anywhere,
if it's a generally seen around the
world as a violator of human rights.
And so when the Bush administration was
not just engaging that justifying
practices like torture and disappearing
people in secret prisons and long term
detention without charge,
uh,
it,
it was very difficult,
not impossible interestingly,
but difficult for the United States to
effectively urge other countries not to
do those things.
I do think,
although I'm critical of some of the
things that the Obama administration has
done,
that,
that he has gone a long way towards,
uh,
not just eliminating those practices but
convincing the world that they are being
eliminated.
I think this is actually a moment,
uh,
perhaps a rare moment when,
um,
the United States government and
particularly the president has a lot of
moral credibility to,
um,
go to the world and champion and end to
torture and,
um,
fair trials for everybody and freedom of
the press and freedom of speech.
Uh,
that moment may not last,
but we do have a moment like that now
and it's important that it be used
effectively and wisely.
Technology can be used to suppress human
rights and to facilitate human rights.
That's always been the case.
Um,
there's never been one technology that,
uh,
is beneficial only to one side and that
struggle.
So governments like China and Iran can
use the Internet to monitor,
uh,
the,
you know,
their people's communication,
um,
to try to identify dissidence,
and go after them individually.
But of course,
um,
campaigners for democracy and human
rights can also use these technologies
as we saw in Iran,
um,
to get around government restrictions on
speech.
And it's a,
it's a tug of war between the,
the dark side of the Internet and the,
and the good side.
Um,
and there's a lot that the United States
can do to,
uh,
to help the,
the good side when in that fight.
Um,
for example,
there are really interesting
technologies being developed that allow
people to communicate privately,
um,
to defeat surveillance and to defeat
censorship,
um,
programs that can be downloaded,
by folks in Iran and China and Burma and
Vietnam.
Um,
and it's something that we've asked the
US government to,
uh,
to fund and support.
There's also,
um,
a very interesting and ambiguous role
played by a American technology
companies like Google and Yahoo and
Cisco.
Um,
these are the companies that develop
these liberating technologies that,
uh,
dissidents in Iran and China use,
but they've also sometimes partnered
with the governments,
um,
to give them,
the technology they use to suppress
dissent.
Um,
they've censored their own content
sometimes.
And so helping these companies figure
out what their responsibilities are when
they are operating in dictatorships and
backing them up when they have to stand
up to those governments is a really
important challenge for the 20th.
[inaudible].